it's one of Islam's most sacred city's
ancient streets and seats of worship and
learning Cara Juan was also the
university home of mass killer sayfudine
res G outside his home there's something
of a crowd gathering to gawp at this now
notorious addressing but it's empty now
it tells us nothing about it now though
we know a lot more about him r SG was a
long-term radicalized jihadist part of a
five-man terror cell operating from the
city's University and he was an Islamic
state sleeper a student on the outside a
terrorist waiting for orders on the
inside many have corroborated this but
was in Bell Adele knew for sure residi
told him he was part of Islamic state
I'm was a jihadist indeed a militant
senator few days Kenny Anasazi waveya
zapathon loss suma Maru
Diamond over here because for the
Illawarra oz mahoba you bet I found a
mcdonald heavy when a circle Meiyappan
be not sure which he convinced that they
were jihadists that he was part of that
circle and that they became not
radicalized then but actually became
part of a structure to carry out terror
attacks combining much more a little gun
at how long it had been only [ __ ] were
him the old woman home and there but
unless julio opportunity for tea oh no
mother hammer in a schoolyard he knew
him well after four years studying
together in the weeks before the attack
he stopped attending class bell Adele
believes he was undergoing final
training in Libya LOL Sihanouk own
attorney before and hooted era but
boniva
no Adrian a la da cunha era di ba what
the Durham shaniqua rozobita resume
sorry Oh be done aunt Alma be home so
lotta Troxy da bahia de tomaso definable
alienation in from terrible are
accompanied with a nokia detomaso de
Olivia bien no handle no Alma Hodge
nasha BF anemia unicum Oscar at lahore
lib una calicut kaweah becomes a massage
area the horrific beachfront murders
were coordinated and funded by Islamic
state bella del and others have no
doubts the Reggie was a disposable
commodity and was groomed for the task
we call this a sleeper cell but it's
it's it's very difficult to do do we
believe it's that sophisticated in the
market no no technique at funky maclir
heavy atop of the value you know mejor
nipa teetotalism area Yenta me
innocently lion-o in a hanya Jana Carter
and magnificent army near habia the
annual could happen today Elliott on
genetic in heavier the matter of circle
about cooling much more una carta
started healing italia walker eating
hanya Holm Monyetta waffle mahabali a
number of people linked to res g have
now been arrested and questioned what's
being asked here though is if so many
openly thought he was a terrorist why
didn't anyone questioned him Stuart
Ramsey Sky News Tunisia